عندما تكون درجة الحرارة 40 أو 50 درجة تحت الصفر،
لا يمكنك إلقاء اللوم على رجل لأنه أخذ
الماء المغلي ونفخ القليل من البخار
وشاهده يتحول على الفور إلى ثلج
وجليد، لكن المصور جو تشانيك من
ألبرتا بكندا استمتع برؤية
ما
فعله الآخرون  ما مدى برودة الجو بما يكفي لاستخدام
موزة عند رطل من المسامير، وهو
بارد بما يكفي لضرب قميص فروزن
مثل
الطبل لتحويل الجينز إلى كبش،
لذلك قرر جو أن يلعب لعبته الخاصة بك،
فجمّدك، ماذا كانت اللعبة التالية؟
طبق نودلز الرامين في 60 ثانية، تم
تجميد المعكرونة المسلوقة بقوة، مجمدة
في الزمن، سلسلة مجمدة في الزمن،
أعتقد أنني أسميها التجربة التالية
التي تتضمن وضع بيضة على شفاطتين وكسرها مفتوحة
وننسى أنها
مسلوقة بشدة.  كنت أتحدث متجمدًا،
كان جيراني ينظرون من النافذة
واعتقدوا أنني مجنون، وأخيرًا
كان هناك شيء ساحر يصنع هذا
السحر حول ما فعله البرد القارس
بورق التواليت، يجب على الناس أن يستغلوا
أفضل الظروف التي يعيشون فيها ولكن
لا تفعلوا ذلك.  حاول استخدامه وإلا فسوف
تجمد مؤخرتك حقًا في
الكلمات الخالدة لآني
لينوكس جيموس سي إن إن نيويورك